I love your smile
my name is huggable this is Aurora are
you feeling a little shy that's okay
what else are you gonna do today what we
have to go to a doctor's appointment oh
okay
whereas to get blood work so much I'm
gonna take your blood from does that
make it easier
the cool thing that we do in designing
robots is that we start with an animated
character end up with a big head big
eyes things that make characters cute to
humans that character design also
involves motions in a certain way that
it moves so the robot is from the
beginning mechanically designed to move
in a certain way it has the capability
to have capacitive sensing to tell when
and how someone's touching it it also
has like swappable hands the goal of
that is eventually to build a sense of
pressure
as a way to indicate pain you kind of
like measure how hard they're squeezing
the robot huggleballs
purpose of existence is to interact on
an emotional level with children hey how
are you I knew it I knew who's fly did
you look about five Tony Orange do you
know any jokes you know I don't know any
jokes what do you want I would love to
what do eggs do for fun hmm
what do eggs do for fun I didn't think
I'd have fun they do karaoke
the hospital I think they do a great job
they have so many activities for us to
do what we were here but the huggable
the fact that Oy is helping you it's
great for the kids we develop them on
huggable app on the smart Android phone
and they put it on the phone and then
phone goes into the face and then we
cover it off with the 3d plastic mask
and cover everything up a fair
but because of the smartphone technology
we can actually put everything inside a
small compact device and it actually
controls all the motors detect all the
sensor information so that's how the
robot became smaller and we're mobile
and you can actually put it right by the
bedside
hey I have an idea what would you like
to play a game with me okay I love to
play iSpy
do you want to go first okay I spy with
my little eye something that is blue Hey
no okay your dad's jeans
no yes again do you want us to give you
in it's somewhere over there over there
love shirts yes spy with my little eye
something pink I'm a hat my goodness you
are so good how did you get that I got
skills
using social robotics in this
environment it firmest it was like oh
how is this gonna work
everything was I think gonna replace
that right and we learned very quickly
that this is just one more tool that we
can use to help children make this a
less frightening experience